logan gilbert making his second career
start
for the seattle mariners we saw his
stuff last time out good 95 mile an hour
heater excellent slider great curveball
and as scott service said look to see
that that slider earlier in the count
maybe even some curve balls earlier in
the ball game tonight against this
detroit lineup he's 2-2 here
swaying and a miss
well done a one-two-three first in his
second big league game ninth appearance
of the year for tarik skoubel's seventh
start for the tigers talented
left-hander zoe and two to kyle seeger
tonight fly ball deep to right center
field get here
[Applause]
kyle seeger has hit all season so well
with runners in scoring position
runner at second base here two outs two
strikes
gets a fastball down and in right where
the lefties like it 107 miles an hour
off the bat there was no doubt about
that one
and that's a huge lift for the mariners
and the tigers have runners at the
corners
and nobody out here in the second inning
eric haas steps to the plate the 2-1
pitch
swinging a shot base hitting the left
field right in between seeger and
crawford into score comes scope mazzara
turns and holds it second base love this
hard contact six batters in
four hard hit balls every ball that has
been put in play has been hit hard that
puts two
in scoring position for wilson ramos
the 2-2 so we're gonna ground ball this
will get a run home wide a third seeger
feels it to his left flips over to first
a little bit high grabbed by mama leos
but infield back ramos took advantage
ground ball to third on a high chop into
score comes mazzara and we're tied at
two in steps harold castro number two
hitting center fielder three-two pitch
hit on the button hannigan right there
wow that's some recovery that is a great
play
that thing must been knuckling and
curving and everything nice play by
mitch haniger well that is just an
outstanding play this ball hit hard
and
mitch initially blake breaks to his
right but then has to put the brakes on
and get back to his left
you're right dave must have been
knuckling there's a little bit of wind
out there probably affected it as well
see his first step here dave to the
right and then he doubles back whoa
just a great athletic play right there
by mitch henniger to save extra bases
omar missouri came in hitting 200. see
if he can give the tigers the lead right
here the payoff there it is he does it
there it is to left field an rbi single
for nomar mizara the tigers are in the
lead to me that's not where your pitcher
is on page
with the defensive coordinator and the
guys that are putting on the shift you
can't throw the ball where they're not
and that's just i mean that's just good
execution but poor execution from the
pitcher he threw the ball right into
where the shift was not
tigers take a 3-2 lead to the top of the
fourth any of the bases are loaded with
tigers here on the fourth but only one
away great opportunity for the tigers
here harold castro at the plate first
pitch swing the line drive left center
field it's gonna drop for a base hit
goodraman to score castro around third
he's coming home the throw from lewis is
cut off on the infield two run single
for harold castro
and the tigers have scored two to take a
5-2 lead here in the fourth 66 pitches
under the belt of tarik skubal as he
begins to work
in the fifth
3-2
got him with a fastball middle of the
strike zone and frozen now the 0.2
foul tipped it into the glove of haas
another strikeout for tarik skubal
there's two away here in the fifth
two two that's a career high
nine strikeouts for tarik skubal his
ninth strikeout eight on swinging third
strikes
ends the fifth
wilson ramos leads off the sixth inning
for the tigers they leave the mariners
5-2
breaks his bat here
jp has time throws him out
2-2 pitch
nice job by montero
with the marmaleos
3-2 pitch
swing and a miss montero outstanding
work six up six down one out one on top
of the seventh inning the old one
swinging a ground ball hit hard left
side crawford has it throws off one leg
to second on to first base it's in time
for the double play to end the inning
the number nine hitter jose marmalejos
the 01
sent to deep center field back with
jacoby jones tracking it leaping he's
got it
and rob jose marmaleos of a home run
terrific timing by jacoby jones he's so
good at that he saw the wall
he gets to the wall he knows where the
ball is coming down here's catcher tom
murphy
[Music]
trying to keep the mariners hopes alive
here in the bottom of the eighth inning
so now murph represents the tying run of
the ball game
tom has four home runs on the season he
hit 18 a couple of years ago
the payoff
broke and that pop up
goodrum handles it nice job by michael
fulmer to end the eight
there's harold castro
look at that
three hits on the night for harold
castro this one's going to drive in
jacoby jones he does what he does as
well as anybody else on this team at 6-2
detroit
just had himself one whale of a night
another line drive
just squaring him right up now that was
a cookie 92 down broadway
but he's in a position to handle it
he's just got such a smooth swing
doesn't he jack
in a way it kind of reminds me a little
bit of rod career yeah absolutely it
does it's gregory soto working the ninth
the wall side windows pitching change
the 1-1
on the ground high hopper
harold castro quickly to scope one away
the 01
to left field grossman back pedals
has it at the edge of the warning track
two away
got him
yes sir he sure did on the outside
corner
13 strikeouts for tigers pitchers
tonight that matches a season best they
sweep seattle
in seattle for the first time
since april of 2006
6-2 the final
heck of an effort for detroit and what a
way to start the road trip